Whoa,
before we go,
before we go Chicago,
UFC.
Ooh,
it's going to be a good one.
Colby Covington don't snappy.
And I said you gonna slap me down.
Slap talking shit.
Well I see you gonna slap you cause I was telling them that Jon Jones might slap
him.
Oh
I like Colby.
I like what he's doing.
He's talking to a lot of shit.
I'm just saying be careful who you talk shit to.
Talking Shit to Jon Jones,
one of the baddest motherfuckers has ever lived.
You know he's making a lot of money.
He's being smart.
Oh,
cold reason why Colby is fighting for the title.
The reason why Kolbe is going to fight Hoffeld dos Anjos for the intern interim
title is not just because he's beaten good guys cause he has,
he beat Damien Maia.
But it's more importantly that he's got,
he's going to put asses in the seats.
Well that's part of the fight business part of the fight business.
Now you've got to sell.
I mean yeah,
especially in our pre and post Conor McGregor,
right.
And Post Conor Mcgregor,
the fucking game has changed.
It's red panties night,
baby.
Everything is different.
It is.
And it's just like,
I see people hate on it on Colby for,
you know,
did he deserve the shot at all?
I know is he wins one fight.
He's holding the belt.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at one more beaten,
pull up his record.
Let me see his record.
If you look at who he's beaten in comparison to somebody,
like there's some people that have been calling him out that can't get a fight
with him tomorrow.
[inaudible] wants to fight him and that guy is a beast.
Yeah.
And then there's some other guys that are really talented but haven't beaten
like any high level guys yet.
Uh,
okay.
So we lost a Warley Alvarez and then look at the guys he's beaten.
Brian Barbarina is a good guy.
Don Young Kim is a,
as a tough guy,
stung on cam and Damien Maia.
That is not really,
I mean,
I'm just going to be honest.
This is not a resume of someone who you would normally see fighting for the
title.
Right now.
I think he's fighting for the title based,
not just on his beat.
Beating Damien Maia,
who's a really tough guy,
but I think on the fact that he's a controversial,
very popular character because he talks so much shit and because he's talked so
much shit about Brazilians and he's fine aided Maya Brazil.
I mean it was,
it was a domination.
He dominated them and it's a w what?
I was a big victory,
but that was his only big victory over a titled a former title Challenger.
Yeah.
Who's like a top level guy who is also 40 years old.
Right.
I mean,
Damien Maia is,
his best days are behind him.
Just as I say this as a huge Damien Maia Fan.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
I look at it is you can't take too much away from Colby because I think of a lot
of great fighters say so.
If you say Nate Diaz,
who's been an icon for years,
one of my favorite of all time,
he's never fought for title.
MM,
right.
Yeah.
No,
sure.
If Colby got there,
however he got there,
he wins one more fight.
He's holding that belt.
I think about fighters who've come up and maybe if they've been,
you know,
quiet or maybe they haven't sold their fights,
maybe like as as well as Colby has.
And so it had been grinding it out,
beating good guys.
Maybe because they've taken that slow road.
Maybe somebody gets lucky and one of these fights and,
and catches him on the Chin and then there are two rungs back and then they got
to grind all the way back up.
That's a lot of damaged.
They're taking,
we're Colby didn't have to,
I mean he played the game the right way for today and it's paying off was one
loss.
Yeah.
I mean I think he's 11 and one now,
but you know,
but other people would say,
well look at guys like Anderson Silva didn't talk any shit.
Just fucked people up.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and became one of the greatest of all time because of that.
Yeah,
it's true.
You know,
you could,
you could look at it like,
do you want to get that shot at the title or do you want to be the greatest
that's ever done it?
Like how,
what is the difference?
I would rather get the title and then show him the greatest.
Right,
right.
They're not mutually exclusive.
No.
Right now.
Yeah.
So I mean,
if he wins,
then he'll probably get it a fight with Woodley.
Right.
He will definitely get a fight with Woodley if he wins 100% right.
So,
so what if,
what if that happens and what if.